um we've also found that these
carjackings
are done by a small number of
individuals out of the 17 we've had this
year already
nine of them are related to multiple
events
that shows us there's a trend with these
certain people going out there and
committing these crimes
we've seen a lot of violence associated
with these carjackings
and the ones i talked about both a force
and firearms were used in both of those
events
that firearm was recovered it was
determined to be a pellet gun
but you couldn't tell until close
inspection that it was a fake firearm or
not a real firearm
we've also seen a trend with vehicle
burglaries across the valley involving
juveniles
several of these crews of individuals
have been taken into custody
and they almost all involve juvenile
crimes so i need the community's help
don't make them easy victims make sure
we go out there we lock our cars
we don't have valuables stored in our
vehicles we're not storing
firearms in our vehicles it's important
that we stay safe and keep this
community safe
and if you see something in your
neighborhood that doesn't belong make
sure you call the police report it to us
whether to see something say something
3-1-1 or if it's in progress
9-1-1 it's imperative we work together
to solve these crimes if they go
unreported
i can't help with getting them solved or
stop them from happening in the first
place
is there any questions regarding this
series of crimes
can you talk about what what is sort of
bringing this on you talked
about it a little bit before but could
you expand on why you think
what are you attributing what are you
attributing this rise in carjackings
and uh there's a lot of theories on what
could be causing this
some of it's social economic some of
it's just crime of opportunity that's
typically what we've seen with our
suspects here locally
is they're looking for crimes of
opportunity at times both of the
carjackings that i was referring to
happened at one and four in the morning
at people at atm machines it's important
we're aware of our surroundings because
we don't want to be that target
and we can make ourselves not be victims
by being aware of our surroundings i
don't
remember every detail right off the top
of your head but mostly early morning
and where do they where do they disperse
geographically geographically they're
all across the valley there's not one
area coming that's getting hit harder
than others
again this is crime of opportunity
they're looking for that
easy victim that's anywhere around the
valley it could be on the east side the
west side it doesn't matter
the reality is we have to be aware of
our surroundings and these kids that are
doing these crimes we have to find a way
to get them into some support networks
that are positive and giving those
positive role models so they're not
going down this road of
to get these kids violence so every air
command at metro has what's called an
intervention officer
and this isn't a one-time visit we're
doing with these kids this is a three
and four month follow-up with these
families
to bring the services around them that
they need to help them be successful not
just as
one individual is that that young man
that's doing these crimes
but the family as a whole if there's
other issues that are causing this we
want to get them addressed on the front
end
so we don't have to complete this cycle
of arresting them putting them into the
criminal justice system
bringing him back out and having that
cycle repeat itself over and over again
we've got to break that
that cycle of crime with these
individuals and these young young men
and women of our society
to make sure they're getting that help
and support they need is there a
specific
area that in other areas i mean
is there sort of a focus that you guys
have i i wish i could say they were
happening in just one area but that's
just not the reality of it they're
happening all across the valley
why'd you choose this area um i'm in
summerlin area command this is important
to me and this is why we're here
um carjacking is happening here i've had
one happen in this area
wondering why you chose this particular
spot yes the 17 car jacking so far this
year how does this compare to
previous years and of those carjackings
you know what percentage would you say
involve juveniles so about 50
involve juveniles and we're at about a
30 percent increase in carjackings from
last
to be sort of the same year there any
indication that they know each other
that this is sort of like a
ring of some kind every time we've
disrupted or arrested a group of these
individuals no matter where it's at we
don't find a lot of connection between
the suspects they are typically that the
suspects will reside in the same area
but they're traveling all over the
valley to commit these crimes
so again we're back to this is a crime
of opportunity they're not they're not
looking for a specific car type they're
not looking for amounts of money
they're looking for that easy target
that they can hit easily and get away
quickly
social media played a factor in any of
these crimes or looking into these
crimes
through the investigation not that i'm
aware of i appreciate your guys time
thank you so much and helping us keep
this valley safe